continuing the pattern of obfuscation of
kicking out a CNN reporter from an event
at the White House instances of
publishing transcripts with parts
missing of framing the media as the
enemy of the American people the Trump
administration is now going to forego
publishing summaries of calls with
foreign leaders and instead issue just a
couple lines of the very general topics
that were discussed and for anyone who
will defend this as saying of course the
Trump administration shouldn't be
publishing these readouts of trumps
calls with foreign leaders those calls
are often filled with classified
information these are non classified
summaries they've always been non
unclassified summaries they're part of
administration protocol Republican
administrations Democratic
administrations for a very long time
have been releasing these and this is a
growing part of the creeping
authoritarianism which we're now
learning of as a result of the BBC's
reporting no more public summaries or
readouts as they are called of the phone
calls Donald Trump has with foreign
leaders and they are going to at their
discretion on their own timeline choose
a few key details to release so first
and foremost that this is mostly
symbolic like either way whether it's a
readout or a couple of points either way
the White House is choosing which
details are included and which details
are excluded right the White House
writes the readout we aren't there for
the calls either way so it's once again
a move against the appearance of
transparency and even against the
expectation of transparency of the Trump
administration which remember supposedly
they were going to be transparent it was
going to be a top transparent
organization not like other
organizations we were going to know what
they were doing and it would all be
swamp draining and great for the
American people the readouts have
already been a problem for the Trump
White House because you will have a
situation where the Trump White House
will publish a readout from a call with
a foreign leader and then the foreign
leaders office will publish a readout of
the same call and they will directly
contradict each other or conflict so
here's one example the
was a call between the Pakistani Prime
Minister Nawaz Sharif and Trump the
Pakistani officials put out a readout
which said that during the call Trump
was a few civil appraising Pakistan and
the president Sharif in the US account
there was nothing about the praise that
Trump gave president Sharif and of
course right away the question was well
what exactly was he praising him for why
is the praise not included and
immediately it becomes a problem for the
Trump White House that they now have to
explain away but what the real problem
here is is not the reduced readouts of
the calls
it's that Trump has reportedly been
giving foreign leaders his personal cell
phone number and is having phone calls
completely off the record altogether so
the debate over readout versus releasing
a few key details sort of becomes a less
relevant debate when you find out that
Trump is giving world leaders his
personal cell phone number and some of
these phone calls are happening
completely off the record it's another
little push in the direction of not
knowing what's being said not knowing
what's going on the White House opting
to provide less information rather than
more at any opportunity to do that and
don't forget that at a recent rally
Trump said to the crowd what you were
seeing and what you are reading is not
what's happening it's part of this
concerted effort this small step by step
move away from democracy and towards
autocracy and imagine just for a second
if it was reported that the Obama White
House was going to stop publishing
readouts of calls and instead they would
just put together a bullet point or two
about what Obama discussed with this
world leader or would that world leader
the right wing the right wing media
apparatus would be going completely
crazy and that's why you have to see
this as part of a broader move away from
democracy White House visitor logs who's
visiting the White House gone pretty
early on in the Trump administration
readouts of calls with foreign leaders
gone to our Putin meeting with Trump
with nobody present almost no press
conferences multiple days a week
cloistered at his own golf clubs no tax
returns released close family members
are senior advisers and this is why it's
really important to understand that it's
a slow creep okay
we had the story about Kushner and
Ivanka work for work for Trump we don't
often think about that now when we see
Trump say that the media is the enemy of
the American people and that's why it's
important to sort of keep track and to
step back and say wow there's a lot of
authoritarian stuff going on the family
works for him he's reducing
communication and transparency about
what he's doing he's blocking individual
media outlets he's talking about
journalism licenses so on so on so on
and I get why Trump would want to do
this right they're constantly having to
walk things back they're constantly
getting caught lying they stop and they
have to explain well this is what we
meant or this is what we actually said
and the only path forward is to vote in
November and the people that voted for
Trump who maybe cared that Trump
promised transparency doesn't seem like
they do because the approval rating is
holding pretty steady this is a
combination of George Orwell's 1984 and
Aldous Huxley's brave new world some
elements more like one some elements
more like the other it is no longer an
exaggeration it is no longer an a
hyperbolic analogy it's very common that
people will say this is just like
Orwell's 1984 when it's really not it is
very common that people will say this is
like what Aldous Huxley described in
brave new world when it's not actually
like that this is like that this is like
that and the only solution at this point
is to vote in November send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we will talk about YouTube
removing some Infowars videos and
suspending an alt right channel from
live broadcasts New Zealand says to
Australia stop copying our flag
Argentina has actually dealt with issues
like that interestingly enough and
failed Alabama Senate candidate Roy
Moore is now filing a defamation lawsuit
over some ads that are running all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show we've got a fan
stick program coming up we will take
your calls we have a great classic
interview and I will also answer some of
your questions upcoming stay with us
this episode is sponsored in part by
better help calm slash Pakman which
gives you access to a fully licensed and
experienced psychologists or therapists
through videophone and text I know from
the emails I get that in our audience
like in the broader world there are
people who are struggling with different
issues in their lives and many of them
choose not to talk to somebody about it
either for financial reasons for reasons
of stigma associated with seeking out a
therapist and I think it's really
important to do everything you can to
get past that because it's really
important to talk to someone when you
feel like that's the right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one the elimination of the stigma
that could be associated with it you
work through video phone whichever
method is best for you
you also will be able to save money
compared to seeing an in-person
therapist and it is so easy to get
started that I encourage you to go to
better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa que ma n